next time on mama Jean from not to on do
you not understand that I'm staying with
my sister and that's how about choice
yes it is if this intervention doesn't
work today they're gonna wind up in jail
or she's gonna die
TV personality mama June and her
boyfriend were arrested temporary
custody I say no because I think if
anybody has any custody over you Ilana
it should be your daddy she's looking at
real time they're either gonna let the
charges go her ass is gonna go to prison
drugs change your whole perspective on
every day oh yeah I am now
so in Alabama someone called the cops
she did your mom did a lot of stuff when
I was out there now this seriously dish
are you for this why they were coming
down the interstate and they were
arguing of course they always do when
they're driving always well apparently
got really heated gino pulled over at
the store and got out and went inside
and got a Red Bull well apparently I can
see the weather on the news day or why
he was in the store mama called the
police twice and hung up there was a
white SUV behind him I guess I followed
them from the interstate so he'd come
back outside and sure enough it was
unmarked police vehicle and that's what
got them so she was scared something yes
something caused whatever happened right
Garrett's her to call the cops
and you gonna be scared enough to call
the police especially for her and she
knows what's going on isn't right she
just never known how to get out of it
but if she would get in her head it's
okay to be a part right just the point
of getting them apart right there's just
a way that's coming out that
this girl has been in my home they've
had sex twice that's the reason why I'm
so emotionally up but once the teacher
on with G that's just the way it is June
I mean he is like my soulmate he is like
the person oh god I can't believe she's
saying that I mean she really needs to
get it together seriously
[Music]